y obviamente hablar de revista de prensa
en directo américa de france 24 y para
ello por supuesto está conmigo en el
estudio rosa pérez master rosa vamos a
abrir esta revista de prensa con una
crónica de los periodistas de associated
press sobre su propia experiencia en
ucrania 20 días en mayo por el equipo
que documentó la agonía de esta ciudad
rosa buenos días raúl exactamente este
es el relato de dos periodistas
ucranianos trabajando para la agencia
estadounidense ap que recordemos
proporciona información y material a los
medios de comunicación de alrededor del
mundo por eso dicen que son los últimos
periodistas internacionales que estaban
en mariupol ellos son mitzila chernoff y
el fotógrafo evgeny malo letra que
relataron la experiencia la experiencia
a sus compañeros lo original y basilisa
stepanenko bien esta crónica cuenta como
los rusos estaban buscando a estos dos
periodistas dicen los rusos nos estaban
persiguiendo nuestros nombres estaban en
su cuentan cómo estaban documentando la
situación en un hospital cuando de
repente llegaron a soldados ucranianos a
preguntar dónde están los periodistas y
que les dijeron que tenían órdenes
directas de sacarlos de mariupol
pudieron a salir pues en bajo bombardeos
en una tensa situación tuvieron que
atravesar 15 checkpoint ser rusos pero
ese día pues recordemos esos días de la
evacuación de convoys en las que decenas
de autos estaban saliendo de la ciudad
llenos de civiles salieron un auto de
hecho con una familia ucraniana una
familia de mariupol y que fue una vez
fuera en una base ucraniana cuando dicen
entendimos porque el ejército ucraniano
no se evacuó y es que un policía les
dijo si los rusos les capturan se
esforzarán a decir delante de la cámara
que todo lo que ustedes han filmado en
mariupol es mentira y todos sus
esfuerzos y todo lo que han hecho en
mariupol será en vano y es que este
equipo de raúl fue el que firmó las
consecuencias del bombardeo ruso en ese
hospital maternal no esas imágenes
terribles que dieron a la vuelta y
también explican cómo de hecho fue un
policía ucraniano el que les llevó hacia
una generador de electricidad y en un
lugar donde más o menos podían tener
conexión para poder hacer llegar esas
imágenes al mundo y es que como decíamos
estos dos periodistas son ucranianos y
dicen que nunca habían tenido tanta
necesidad de romper el silencio y de
explicar a la gente alrededor del mundo
lo que estaba sucediendo bajo estos
ataques rusos en mariupol porque
recordemos el resto de periodistas
internacionales salieron cuando
empezaron a cortar las comunicaciones en
esa ciudad y es que una de las razones
que el ejército ruso corte las
comunicaciones pues el mariupol es
intentar pues ejercer no los bombardeos
los crímenes con total impunidad qué
triste rosa ese relato a massa muy
interesante los invitamos por supuesto a
que usted pueda ampliarlo en esta
agencia de noticias pero continuamos con
una revelación del proyecto para
reportar el crimen organizado y también
la corrupción o rosal aussies y aquí por
sus siglas en inglés esta es la misma
organización de periodistas que sacó a
la luz la investigación de suisse
efectivamente y ahora lo que reportan es
que mientras países alrededor del mundo
están imponiendo sanciones contra los
oligarcas aliados de putin pues ellos
están escondiendo su riqueza en una
cuentas secretas y en estructuras
offshore y esta organización empieza a
rastreando la lista elaborada por la
fundación de alexéi navalni se llaman
nombres que participan de la opresión y
la corrupción del régimen de putin y
dicen que seguirán ampliando con amasa
nombres pues estos días más adelante y
miremos esta plataforma que se puede
consultar en español también simplemente
a nosotros no nos funcionaba la página
en nuestros momentos pero aquí podemos
entrar y vemos pues esta lista no estos
nombres entre los que figuran por
ejemplo roman abramovich que es el
propietario del club de fútbol de
londres el chelsea pero también está el
portavoz de vladimir putin o el fiscal
de moscú pero para hacerles entender
cómo funciona esta herramienta nos
centramos en el perfil de roman
abramovich lo vemos en el siguiente
gráfico
entramos pues en el perfil de cada uno
de estos oligarcas podemos ver el valor
estimado de la fortuna que mantienen a
día de hoy a pesar de estas sanciones en
este caso vemos como su fortuna es de
más de ocho mil millones de dólares
también nos explica que esta fortuna
pues la creó en base a la industria
petrolera y que ha sido sancionado pues
también veíamos ahí por el reino unido
canadá de la unión europea junto con las
fechas de las sanciones y también vemos
sus activos destacados no vemos
propiedades en europa también compañías
edificios hoteles pues el propio chelsea
el estadio del chelsea en stamford
brigde helicópteros aviones bueno no
acabaríamos no raúl rosa y parece es
chistoso porque parece que fuera como un
sitio de para alquilar casas hoteles y
realmente son las propiedades de una
persona no exactamente ahora vamos a
fijarnos también en lo que publicó mayo
russel como nos caía braf está que
tenemos aquí a menudo ayer lunes publicó
una información y la borró inmediato de
qué estamos hablando rosa pues habían
como dices a este medio que se considera
afín al kremlin público en un artículo
que el número de bajas entre las filas
del ejército ruso sería de nueve mil
861 soldados muertos en esta invasión de
ucrania y más de 16.000 heridos una
cifra que dista muchísimo de la oficial
publicada por el kremlin a principios
del mes de marzo que no se ha
actualizado desde entonces y que es de
cuatrocientos noventa y ocho muertos
bien como decías no este medio eliminó
de inmediato esta información que por
ejemplo el foreign affairs atribuye a lo
que podría ser una filtración o un
hackeo pues del ministerio de defensa
ruso raúl pues rosa gracias entonces por
toda esta información de revista de
prensa el día de hoy martes nos vemos
mañana con más pero pasamos a saludar a
nuestro primer invitado el día